.
THAT JOKE DIDN'T GO AS WELL AS I
THOUGHT IT WAS, EVEN THOUGH I'M
PLAYING THE HOME FAME.
DONNA, WE'RE AT THE JERSEY
SHORE, A LOT OF LANDLORDS,
TENANTS COME IN THE SUMMER.
THE CDC TOLD YOU, DONNA, TOLD
YOU CAN'T ELECT?
>> WHO ELECTED THEM?
THAT WOMAN 12 YEARS AGO WAS A
COLLEGE PROFESSOR.
TELLING PEOPLE LIKE ME, WHO ARE
NOT WEALTHY LANDOWNERS WE CAN'T
COLLECT OUR RENT.
HOW WOULD THE GOVERNMENT LIKE
IT, WELL THE CDC SAID WE DON'T
HAVE TO PAY OUR TAXES BECAUSE OF
COVID?
HOW WOULD THEY LIKE THAT?
AND OUR BANKS, THAT WE HAVE
MORTGAGES?
THEY'RE HURTING US.
WE CAN'T LIVE LIKE THIS FOREVER
AND NOT COLLECT RENT AND CARRY A
TENANT THAT IS SITTING HOME,
COLLECTING A CHECK FROM THE
GOVERNMENT FOR A SIZABLE AMOUNT
EVERY MONTH, SITTING IN OUR
PROPERTY WHILE WE GET STUCK
HOLDING THE BILL.
>> IT'S A SENTIMENT BEFUDDLING
HOW THIS CONCEPT HASN'T GOTTEN
THROUGH THE TO THE GOVERNMENT.
THERE ARE WAYS TO ACCOMPLISHING
GOALS BUT IGNORE LITERALLY HALF
THE LANDLORD TENANT
RELATIONSHIP, STEP INTO A
PRIVATE CONTRACT, WILL AS A
LAWYER, THIS IS A TAKING.
IT IS A FLAT-OUT TAKING.
IT IS UNBELIEVABLE THAT IT IS
HAPPENING.
A LOT MORE GREAT OPINIONS COMING
UP THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF THE
MORNING.
BACK TO YOU.
WILL: THAT IS EXACTLY HOW I
DESCRIBED IT ON THE LATEST
EPISODE OF THE WILL CAIN
PODCAST, BIG IN AMERICA, NOT IN
KOREA.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT IS A TAKING
THAT THE GOVERNMENT IS
CONFISCATING PROPERTY FROM
LANDLORDS BY DENYING THEM THE
ABILITY TO COLLECT RENT WHILE
STILL REQUIRING THEM TO HOLD
TRUE TO THEIR MORTGAGE AND
PROPERTY TAXES.
IT MAKES NO ECONOMIC SENSE.
IT MAKES NO MORAL SENSE.
IT DOESN'T MAKE LEGAL SENSE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION KNOWS
THAT AS WELL.
PETE: THAT IS EXACTLY RIGHT.
THEY KNEW THEY COULDN'T EXTEND
IT.
THEY CALLED ON CONGRESS TO IT.
THEY KNEW CONGRESS WOULDN'T DO
IT.
SO THEY CALLED ON THE CDC TO DO
IT?
HOW DOES THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE
CONTROL HAVE THE POWER TO EXTEND
RENT MORATORIUMS.
WILL: WE CHECK EACH OTHER DURING
THE COMMERCIAL BREAKS.
ARE WE GOING INSANE?
HOW US DID THE CDC HAVE THE